i don't want to spend a lot of time on
this because i don't have a lot of time
to spend on this
but um marjorie taylor green must be
removed from the house of
representatives
she appeared on sebastian gorka's
program yesterday this was one of
trump's many various advisors and she
suggested using second amendment rights
against democrats she actually says in
this segment the reason we have the
second amendment is so that we can use
it against people who are you doing the
things democrats are doing right now she
should be removed from from the house
take a look at this
they're coming for our guns and for our
civil rights are they not
they're not but okay
oh of course they are as a matter of
fact stacy abrams who is running for
governor for the second time in georgia
in her announcement speech after she
said that she would pursue aggressive
vaccinations of georgian
she the next thing she talked about was
grabbing people's guns she hates
georgia's second amendment
rights she she wants to stop
constitutional carry which is exactly
what our state legislators and our
governors should be pursuing right now
they should be passing it and signing it
into law
but yeah no democrats they hate our
second amendment because ultimately the
truth is it's our second amendment
rights our right to bear arms that
protect americans and give us the
ability to defend ourselves from a
tyrannical government now remember there
are no prominent democrats suggesting
getting rid of the second amendment and
there is no serious legal opinion that
some regulations around firearms violate
the second amendment these are widely
established uh principles of law at this
point but doesn't matter to her and and
i hate to use this language but
democrats uh
they're exactly they're doing exactly
what our founders talked about when they
gave us these precious rights that we
have and and you know no one wants
violence and i say it all the time i'm
not a violent person and i hope to never
see a civil war in this country and
that's why you hear me toss around uh
national divorce because the federal
government has grown so big uh and and
the democrats are willing to use the
power of the federal government that
that it really violates people's rights
and this is why state rights are so
important and um it's a shame we
shouldn't think that way but uh you know
i don't know what's going to happen in
the future but we always have to make
sure that we're defending our second
amendment right so the key line there is
democrats are doing the things
for which the founders gave us the
second amendment to protect us against
she's saying democrats are doing things
worthy
of so-called second amendment solutions
she should be removed from congress
immediately it's like a do not pass go
do not collect 200 just get out
unfortunately expulsion from congress
requires a resolution to expel in the
ethics committee
an investigation over the alleged
actions and then a two-thirds vote
democrats will never get a two-thirds
vote to expel marjorie taylor green in
the house unless she quite literally was
charged with a felony because most
republicans think this is fine
uh and you know what she's going to get
reelected that's the scariest part you
know jewish space lasers starting forest
fires at this point it really shouldn't
shock us
but despite all of it she's going to get
reelected isn't the secret service
obligated to investigate her at this
point and these people with the violence
and the guns and they still get into
power and obviously we have to say this
says something about them that they keep
electing people with these these
sort of violent fantasies madison
cawthorne and others talking about using
second amendment uh solutions against
democrats and i guess it's sort of like
they they love violence they just don't
want the people on their side to be
subjected to it but they don't really
have a problem with violence and it is
without a doubt a form of stochastic
terrorism this woman is disgusting